hi my name is Olivia I'm a senior
studying mechanical engineering and
human centered design and I'm currently
the editor-in-chief of imprint magazine
infinite magazine is the student-run art
and fashion magazine on campus we really
want to provide a creative outlet for
all of our students studying technical
studies in addition were places for
people to explore and have fun
I'm Hamilton Forsythe I'm a junior I'm
studying arts and design which is in the
architecture department I would say the
mission statement is to give a voice to
the people who feel like they're
underrepresented here at MIT which
directly relates to fashion and design
and culture and how we integrate those
things with technology here at MIT I
think coming out of high school I was
trying to find some way to explore
myself and explore who I was as an
individual and fashion really allowed me
to do that so the magazine has a bunch
of different ideas categorize into
spreads and each spread starts with a
student idea so it's even will come and
approach us saying oh I want to explore
this topic in my visual spread and we
help the iterate and refine that idea
into something that could be presentable
in a magazine from there we help them
secure material secure models we have
photoshoots and then we have people lay
the spread out in InDesign it's a great
balance between group and individual
work as a busy I want to student you
know you can't do every aspect of every
design and you might not even have the
skills to do those things as well I
think the most interesting project that
influenced ever done is the launch box
that we did last issue for our launch
event we created a template by 10-foot
room I was kind of bodega style it was
an interactive art exhibit of pages and
images from the magazine and people
could walk in take pictures explore the
magazine in a physical sense instead of
just quickly today's launch and last
semester was something that I've
contributed the most soon felt the most
proud of being able to actually come up
with that idea and build the launch box
from scratch on my own makes it really
really important to me the Internet
community is pretty special to me it's a
large group of people but what makes it
special is that we're all interested in
growing creatively and we're all really
supportive of each other's individual
projects I definitely want to keep
expanding infinite
making it more visible not only at MIT I
also want to start reaching out into
Boston area and just put MIT on the map
as a place to be for you know fashion
design
[Music]